[Música]
es un gran día para la ciencia es un
gran día para la humanidad cuando te das
cuenta que tu vacuna tiene un 90 por
ciento de efectividad es abrumador
[Música]
la vacuna fue la mejor noticia
científica del año porque hemos visto
que estamos avanzando en el tratamiento
de colitis 9 dyn - ser una madre tiene
78 años cumplirá 79 en breve y ya le
dije mamá asegúrate de que cuando te
llamen estés lista estate preparada para
abordar esto es muy importante para ti
debido a tu edad así que atenta para
hacer llamadas justin bieber y chico
[Música]
el punto aquí es que dado el volumen y
la velocidad de distribución de vacunas
independientemente de que se almacene de
2 a 8 grados centígrados oa menos 80
grados ninguna cadena de frío de vacunas
está lista o es capaz de satisfacer este
volumen de demanda el último
[Música]
y sabemos que esta vacuna es lo que
llamamos reactogénicas causa muchas
reacciones locales dolor en los brazos y
duele al entrar
además algunas personas se sienten un
poco débiles durante un día o dos y
pueden tener dolor de cabeza y la
segunda dosis porque esto es una vacuna
de dos dosis separadas por un mes la
segunda dosis a menudo duele incluso más
que la primera por lo tanto tendremos
que informar a todo el mundo sobre esto
y nos gustaría ver todos los detalles
el ensayo de la vacuna
rosa en venezuela va muy bien
vamos a esperar que termine todo el
ensayo para poder dar los resultados
definitivos pero va muy bien
[Música]
china y brasil han llevado a cabo una
sólida cooperación en la lucha contra la
pandemia y creemos que estas relaciones
contribuirán a la victoria completa de
ambas naciones así como de la gente de
todos los países del mundo sobre la
pandemia
el virus afectó mucho nuestro trabajo
nuestra vida social y nuestras
relaciones sociales ojalá la vacuna
tenga éxito y nos devuelva a los viejos
tiempos incluso nuestra moral ha sido
diferente sufrimos de depresión sentimos
que algo está mal en la vida ojalá
volvamos a los viejos tiempos
bueno no tomaré la vacuna a todos con
los que hablo nadie dice que quiere
tomarla pero creo que van a intentar
imponerle a la gente
es novak sin force o existe una vacuna
para la pobreza el hambre el cambio
climático o la desigualdad
ninguno de estos desafíos puede
abordarse de forma aislada están
profundamente interrelacionados y así
debe ser nuestra respuesta
cómo podemos estar seguros de que todo
el mundo está jugando el juego que no
hay un comportamiento clandestino que
produciremos dosis suficientes para los
países más pobres que más las
necesitarán porque no venceremos al
virus o abandonando a parte de la
humanidad
[Música]